if they can push things like covet and
vaxes and mandates and all of this stuff
that they can break you and that you
will just be well owning nothing and
eating bugs and loving it and guess what
they're not stopping they really are not
stopping it's it's a little depressing I
suppose but they are not stopping and I
promise you they won't win they just
won't win it's not out it's not how
history Works uh at the G20 uh they are
now supporting which of course is
connected to the world economic forum
and all these things they are now
supporting unanimous vaccine passports
you they're sorry they're unanimously
supporting vaccine passports and leaders
of the G20 are unanimously supporting a
global vaccine passport system G20 of
course the group of 20 major economies
including the US the EU and China
the 20 members agreed to it after
finishing their Summit in Indonesia
here's Indonesia's minister of Health
let's have a digital health certificate
acknowledged by who
if you have been vaccinated or tested
properly then you can move around
so for the next pandemic instead of
stopping the movement of the people 100
with clocked the economy globally you
know you can still provide some movement
of the people
so give people Freedom by taking away
their freedom got it
man
like does it make you a conspiracy
theorist to think that covet was
basically planned whether it was the lab
leak or however this all happened that
it was going to lead to this I mean two
and a half years ago people talking
about how this was all going to lead to
digital passports and all of these
things I mean what what I just want to
be very clear to you G20 people a new
world economic foreign people and you
Klaus Schwab I'm never getting the
vaccine and if that means that I can't
leave the free state of Florida then you
know what so be it I'll be here with the
iguanas and I'll be here with the frogs
and the lizards and I guess I'll be here
with you guys and that's it and then
maybe I'll just be able to go to your
house and you guys all live in the same
building but that it'll just be a very
short trip and I'll visit each one of
you